right dear friends
dear colleagues
i think uh let's get started we've uh
had a lot of informal discussions i
think let's uh
get on with the informal stock taking
plenary
so friends we've uh had months of vital
discussions
we've had two incredibly intense weeks
of negotiations in glasgow
and we arrive
at what i believe is the moment of truth
and this is the moment of truth
for our planet
and it's a moment of truth for our
children and our grandchildren
and you all know
that the world is willing us on to be
bold to be ambitious
and so much rest on the decisions that
we collectively take today
but you know that already
so let me start first by thanking you
once again from the bottom of my heart
for your hard work
which for some is the culmination of
several years of efforts
and i am deeply grateful to the ministry
of facilitators who have helped us to
shift gears and make progress this week
and i'd like to also like to thank my
team and of course our friends the unf
triple c sectariat for their intense
efforts to convert the fruits of
yesterday's discussions into revised
texts overnight issued under my
authority as president
these texts
are now clean
and we believe that they are the product
of a transparent inclusive and
party-driven process
and has been
founded on listening and the search for
consensus
and they've been co-created with you
they've been revised they've been tested
and they've been revised once again
now can i just say friends very candidly
that you all know the nature of these
negotiations
as presidency we have effectively had to
take into account and balance the views
of almost 200 parties
and i completely understand
that parties sometimes have different
priorities
and yet we all ultimately have to sign
up to the same agreement
i hope however that you share my view
that taken together
these latest iterations represent the
comprehensive
ambitious and balanced set of outcomes
that you can collectively that you
collectively call for in yesterday's
informal plenary and indeed in the
intense discussions which ran into the
early hours of this morning
outcomes that serve to keep within reach
the paris temperature goal of limiting
global warming to well below 2 degrees
and pursuing efforts to limit warming to
1.5 within reach
outcomes that will facilitate the rapid
scale-up of action and support on
adaptation
that lay the ground for mobilizing the
increased climate finance needed to
achieve the goals of the paris agreement
and that elevate the importance of
averting minimizing and addressing loss
and damage including through
strengthened institutional arrangements
we're all well aware that collectively
our climate ambition and action to date
have fallen short of delivering on the
promises made in paris
and importantly these texts recognized
this and set out a clear response
now
whilst many will call for that response
to go even further
these decisions i believe set out
tangible next steps and very clear
milestones to get us on track to meet
the goals of the paris agreement across
each of the three pillars of this
process mitigation adaptation and
finance
and they're guided by equity and common
but differentiated responsibilities and
respective capabilities in the light of
different national circumstances
importantly
these tests texts also provide a way
forward on the three outstanding
elements of the paris rulebook
common time frames the enhanced
transparency framework and article six
consensus on these issues friends have
evaded us for far too long
today's texts reflect the compromise
reached through the effort collaboration
and civil discourse of each and every
one of you
and once adopted they will facilitate
the full and effective implementation of
the paris agreement
these texts along with decisions already
adopted
respond to the unprecedented agenda that
we faced coming into this conference and
demonstrate that parties came to glasgow
to deliver on their mandates leaving no
issue behind
so friends we have reached a critical
juncture
where we must come together
and bring our hard work to a successful
conclusion
you're all skilled negotiators and your
committed champions of your national
interests and i respect that
and of course we are at that stage in
the negotiation when you and your
delegations may be asking yourselves
whether you can leverage this moment to
deliver more for your country for your
region or your group
and i implore you
not to
please do not ask yourself what more you
can seek
but ask instead
what is enough
is this package
balanced
does it provide enough for all of us
and you have to ask yourself
whether taken together
these texts represent a fair balance
for your government for all parties and
with progress being made on all issues
and most importantly
please ask yourselves
whether ultimately these texts deliver
for all our people
and our planet
we know that the climate crisis is a
truly global challenge
and ensuring the cop 26 outcomes
match the scale and urgency of our
situation is our shared responsibility
as i said at the start of this
conference
we will succeed or fail
as one
so i propose
that
we will shortly adjourn this informal
plenary to enable the final finalization
of documents and that we meet again this
afternoon for the final closing
plenaries of the cop the cmp and the cma
and as i said earlier
we do want to conclude this cop
this afternoon
friends the world is watching us
they're willing us to reach an agreement
here for the sake of our planet and for
present and future generations
i believe
that the texts before you deliver on the
expectations the priorities that you
have communicated to my team and to me
over the past two years and they do so
in a balanced manner leaving no issue
and no party behind
and so i invite you to join together
this afternoon to bring this collective
effort to a successful conclusion
to demonstrate that unity of purpose
that our leaders
at the start of this summit and indeed
our people across the world demand
so what i would like to propose
is that we now
adjourn this meeting